PROFESSOR: OK,
welcome back to 6849.
So last lecture,
lecture three, we
were talking about
local foldability
and some complicated flat
folding, like a flapping bird
here.
We were looking at a
single vertex and locally
around that vertex
what properties
it would have to have.
And we saw Kawasaki's theorem
which characterized the angles.
And without a mountain
valley assignment
Kawasaki was all you needed.
The alternating sum
of angles should be 0.
And given a mountain
valley pattern, locally
we characterize things
as a sequence, anything
you can do by a
sequence of crimps.
So sort of a similar
version to lecture
two, which was about
1D flat foldability.
There we needed
crimps and end folds.
Here we needed just
crimps, which is easier.
So I'm going to
jump into questions.
And in particular, this
is an opportunity for me
to talk about the main
thing that I skipped
last class, class two,
because it relates again
to this lecture, which is how
do we do this algorithmically?
So it's one thing
to say, oh, just
do crimps and end folds
till you can't anymore,
and then when you run out of
stuff to do, if you're done,
you're done, otherwise
it's not flat foldable.
That's true.
But the obvious way to
implement that algorithm
is to sweep over
the crease pattern,
look for any crimps
or end folds.
If you find one, do it, and
then repeat and keep sweeping.
And that would take
quadratic time,
because in the worst
case every scan
you have to look through
the whole pattern
and at the very end you
find what you need to do.
So after about n
operations-- n is
the number of creases
in your pattern--
you find what you need to
do, you do the operation,
and then you repeat.
So n plus n plus n, n
times, is n squared.
But you can do
better and it's been
alluded to in the lectures,
but it wasn't covered.
And so I wanted to cover
it, because there's actually
a really simple way to do it.
There's one version
in the textbook,
but there is a simpler way.
So I want to talk about that.
This is a new way we
just invented last week?
This week?
I forget.
So I'm going to first talk
about it in the 1D scenario,
but it's pretty much
the same for both.
1D's a little bit easier
to think about, though.
So 1D mountain valley
pattern something like this.
So I'm going to follow
the same approach, which
is sweep left to right
until I find either an end
fold or a crimp that I can do.
So in this case, maybe this
would be the first thing
that I find sweeping
left to right.
That's a crimpable pair--
or crimpable segment,
I'm going to call it-- is just
one that is locally smallest.
It's less than or equal to
its two neighbors in length,
and it has two different
assignments, M/V or V/M.
So that's a crimpable
pair, because it's
shorter than those two guys.
So that's the basic
algorithm, but what
I do after that is going to
be a little bit different.
So I want to search left to
right for a segment that's
either crimpable
or end foldable.
And there's two situations.
If I don't find any operations
to do, then we stop.
And if there are
any creases left
we know that the
resulting thing is not
flat foldable from what
we proved in lecture two.
If there's no crimp or end
fold, you're not flat foldable.
But if you do find
something, then do the fold.
This is so far pretty obvious.
I'm going to draw the picture
for a crimp situation.
So in the crimp
situation-- these
are the previous
and next creases--
we have these
lengths x, y, and z.
We know that y is less than
or equal to z and is less than
or equal to x.
And after we do the
crimp, it looks like this.
So we have x, y, and
z here, but we're
then going to fuse
this material together,
because these creases
are done with.
We don't really care about them.
The new length that we
get is x minus y plus z.
OK.
So that's what I
mean by do the fold.
And we'll also call this
sort of merging the segments,
meaning replace-- so normally
we have a sequence of lengths--
replace x, y, z with
x minus y plus z,
remove these two creases
which were, say, M and V.
Now we want to continue.
And the realization
is that we don't
have to start over our
search in searching
left to right for
a crimpable thing.
If we went all the way
through the pattern
and then finally found
a crimp at the end,
should we start way back here?
No.
There's no point.
You might as well start
basically where you just were.
Not quite.
You have to go back one step.
So the next step in this
algorithm is go back one step,
and then continue the search.
Back means left.
And the search is this line.
OK.
So that's an algorithm,
a little loop there.
So in this example we-- the
point of what's going on
and the reason this
algorithm is correct
is we just modified
these three segments.
And we replaced
these three segments
with a single segment which
looks something like that.
And the rest, the parts to
the left and to the right
are the same.
I still claim we need
to back up one segment
and look at this one again,
because now potentially
this one might be crimpable
whereas it wasn't before.
Because we changed
this length, it
may have gotten
longer potentially.
Or shorter.
It could have changed.
So this pair may be crimpable
whereas it wasn't before.
So just to make sure,
we'll go left one step,
and then we'll check, is
that segment crimpable?
Is this one?
And just keep going.
And I'm guessing
this pattern is not
is not flat foldable
because of these two.
We could check.
Did I miss one?
V, M, M. M is the little thing.
So I think this
is going to crimp.
And then this will
get end folded.
But still this is a problem
because of the two M's.
So this will not flat fold.
We'll be left with
something like this,
which is the two M's
and then we say, oh.
We'll reach the stop case.
Can't find a crimp
or and end fold
and there are
still creases left.
And so we know that
we're not flat foldable.
But the reason I'm doing this
fast resume of the search,
continuing the search
from one step to the left,
is because we get a
good running time.
I'm going to use running
time notation of order n.
This means some
constant times n.
We don't really care what the
constant is, but the growth is
linear in the number
of creases that's n.
And the reason it's
linear is that the number
of rightward steps
that we make is
going to be equal to n plus
the number of leftward steps.
Why is that?
Because overall the search
is going left to right,
and if it doesn't find
anything it just takes n steps.
You look at all the creases
or all the segments.
It's basically n,
n plus 1, whatever.
For each one, you check is
it crimpable, end foldable.
That takes constant time.
You're just comparing
a couple of numbers.
So I'm counting the
number of rightward steps.
The trouble with the
search is that every time I
find a fold to do
I go back one step
and so I'm kind
of losing progress
because I go backwards.
There's actually two
reasons why that's OK.
One is you're also decreasing
n at the same time,
because you're replacing
3 things with 1 thing,
so n goes down by 2.
But also, in order to
make a rightward step
either it's in the
full search or it's
because you went back one and
you have to go right again.
So this is true.
And the point is the number
of leftward steps is also
at most n, because
every time you
do a leftward step
you did a fold,
and there's only
n folds to make.
So-- it's actually less,
because crimps do two at a time.
But the point is
this is at most 2n.
And so the number of rightward
steps we make is linear.
And so the overall
running time is linear.
For the algorithms people, this
is a very simple amortization
argument.
We're charging the
leftward steps to the folds
that we're doing.
So that's an easy way to
do 1D flat foldability
testing for mountain
valley patterns.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why do you
need to go back a step?
So, the segment
that you labelled x,
its new length is x plus
the quantity z minus y,
and z is greater than y.
So it's x plus a
positive number, right?
So it's only increasing
in length, not decreasing.
PROFESSOR: Only increasing.
But that's of interest, right?
Because if you had something
that wasn't crimpable
because this was too short, and
then-- OK, here's an example.
Good question.
I hadn't thoroughly checked.
So we scan.
This guy's not crimpable
because this guy's too short.
Then we reach-- suppose
then we jump to this guy.
I'll do valley mountain to make
this definitely not crimpable.
We look at this guy.
We do the crimp.
And now suddenly we have
this nice big length.
And so now this
pair is crimpable.
Good.
So that's why we need
to go back a step.
After we crimp
this guy, this one
becomes crimpable
if it wasn't before.
Yeah.
I could have easily believed
that this step wasn't
necessary, but it
definitely doesn't hurt
and it is indeed necessary.
The key is that we don't have
to back up more than one step,
because we're only changing
our neighbors, basically.
Other questions
about this algorithm?
OK, well once we have this for--
this is really for lecture two
material, we can adapt it to
lecture three material, which
is the circular case.
Instead of having a line
we have a circle of paper.
In that case, we only
need to look for crimps,
and so we do the same
thing for crimps.
I don't think I really need to
write this down, but algorithm
for a single vertex
mountain valley pattern.
It's basically the
same algorithm.
Instead of wherever
you see left and right
you replace it with clockwise
and counterclockwise
going around in a circle.
There's no obvious
starting point
you just start at an arbitrary
segment, which in this case
is an angle of the
crease pattern.
Maybe I should draw a
little crease pattern, just
for a picture.
So you start, let's
say, at this segment.
You see is this pair crimpable.
If not continue,
let's say, clockwise.
Keep going.
If you ever find a crimpable
pair, like these two guys--
maybe this is
mountain and valley
and this is a locally
smallest angle--
you do the crimp, meaning
you replace this angle x y
and z with x minus y
plus z, just as before.
And then you step
counterclockwise one step.
And the point is
the invariant you're
maintaining at all times during
this algorithm, the interval
of the segments from the very
first segment you went to,
up to but not
including the segment
you're currently
looking at, those
are all guaranteed not
crimpable at the moment.
And so when you do a crimp,
that may invalidate this one,
and so you have to step
backwards because you're not
sure whether that one's
crimpable anymore.
But you maintain that invariant.
And so when if you ever get
back to the original angle
that you were considering,
the original segment,
then you know that in fact
everything is not crimpable,
and then you're in trouble.
Maybe.
Except for this issue
which I also forgot about
in lecture three-- I mean, I
didn't forget about this time,
but I forgot about it then--
which is in the base case.
You can never actually do
everything by crimping,
because at the
very end your hope
is that you have a cone
with two creases that
are both the same orientation.
That is your goal.
You know that there's two more
mountains or two more valleys
and crimps pair them up.
So you hope that you end
up with the situation.
If you do, and these
two angles are equal,
then you're flat foldable.
You have that one
last fold to make.
Otherwise, if you have anything
else, you're not flat foldable.
That's what we proved
in lecture three,
is that crimps are enough to
get down to this situation
where you have only
two creases left,
and that's what's foldable
when you only have two creases.
OK so this is becoming a cone
as soon as you do operations.
It's just like the
analysis we did.
But this algorithm
will run in linear time
for the same reason.
The number of clockwise
steps equals at most n
plus the number of
counterclockwise steps.
And so I guess I should
maybe write "at most."
And so this is
linear time as well.
Any questions about
those algorithms?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: For the
simple one, could you
run into some edge case
where the very last crimp
you considered makes the
very first one, which
wasn't crimpable,
crimpable and then you
have to go around
the circle again?
PROFESSOR: Ah.
OK.
Good question.
Right.
So we said, OK, this is
guaranteed not crimpable,
but if you then crimp
the very last segment
this one may become crimpable,
and then that may propagate
and force you to go
around a second time.
AUDIENCE: So if that happens
at each step, then at each step
you go all the way around,
and it could become quadratic.
PROFESSOR: Ooh, interesting.
AUDIENCE: But I'm
not sure if it's
possible for that to
happen every step.
PROFESSOR: Good.
Well, this is the nature
of new algorithms.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The set of
possibly crimpable things
increases by at most 1 every
time-- or at most 2 every time
you make a crimp.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So certainly you will only have
to go around at most n times,
but a quadratic bound
overall is not very exciting.
AUDIENCE: So it stays linear.
The interval in which things
are possibly crimpable
expands by at most 2 every
time you make a crimp.
PROFESSOR: I see.
OK.
So this is a different
algorithm, unfortunately.
But you maintain the
interval of things
that are guaranteed
not crimpable
and you can look at
both ends whether you
can crimp something.
If you can, fine, you do it.
You shrink the
interval a little bit.
So in general your interval
is-- I have colored chalk,
I should use it-- your
interval is an interval.
It starts somewhere,
ends somewhere.
And you're checking
is this guy crimpable.
If it's not crimpable
you can extend
the interval a little bit.
If it is crimpable
you do the fold
and you actually shrink
the interval a little bit.
But every time you shrink
the interval, you did a fold,
and that only happens n times.
Every time you grow the
interval, you grew the interval
and you can only grow n times.
Good.
So that will clean
up this situation.
If this ends up being
crimpable, you just
shrink the interval
from the other side.
So I guess if I
wanted to just tweak
this algorithm I would
change the notion of first.
So I said, oh, this guy is
the first one that I visited.
But if I end up
crimping this guy,
I have to advance the first
to be the very next interval.
Good.
Thank you.
All right.
I'll correct that in
the notes as well.
It was almost correct.
Think now that
should be correct.
Thanks for checking.
And now we can do
it in linear time.
There's a different
algorithm in the textbook,
which uses more data structures.
This I like because
it's very simple.
It's just, like, storing
two pointers and that's it.
Other questions?
OK.
That does algorithms.
That was the new material
I wanted to cover.
Then there is the other--
the actual algorithm that
was briefly described in class
is this local foldability
algorithm.
So you have now not
just a single vertex,
but you have a whole
crease pattern.
You'd like to assign a mountain
valley assignment to it that
is at least locally
good, that when
you run this algorithm
at each vertex it gives
the right answer, it
says that, yeah, it's
locally foldable
for each vertex.
It doesn't mean the whole
thing will fold flat,
but it's a start, at least.
It's a necessary
condition for that.
So I just want to give
you a few examples
of this algorithm,
because it is confusing.
I didn't do any
examples in lecture.
It's always been the most
confusing part to me,
and especially this notion
of merging cycles and paths.
So for starters, these are
the examples in the textbook.
They're pretty simple, but at
least they'll get us warmed up.
So the crease pattern
is the bold black lines.
It's two of them.
And in this case it's
the generic case,
so there's a unique
pairing here.
There's only one crimpable
pair, which are these two guys.
This is the only
locally smallest angle.
So those two have
to be crimped first.
One's going to be a mountain,
one's going to be a valley.
So we would write not
equals in this blue thing
to represent that constraint.
This will be all that's left.
And so these two guys
have to be equal.
It's symmetric, so it looks
the same all the way around.
And so when you see, OK, these
two guys have to be not equal,
but also these two guys
have to be not equal,
this is what we call a
cycle of constraints.
In general, you get paths.
Like, this one starts
and ends at infinity,
so these two guys
have to be equal,
these two guys have to be equal.
They could both be mountain,
both be valley, doesn't matter.
These are the only constraints.
But this cycle--
cycles can be problems,
and here because it's
an odd cycle of not
equals there's no
way to assign it.
If you say mountain,
valley, mountain,
then these two guys
are both mountains,
which violates that constraint.
In general, the
number of not equals
should be even in each cycle.
If it's ever an odd number of
not equals, you're in trouble.
Here's an example where
the cycle is even,
but we end up with
an equals here,
and so the number of
not equals is still odd,
so this is also bad.
I mean, it's just replacing this
segment with two equal creases.
Still can't assign a
mountain or valley.
But these are kind
of simple examples.
These are cycles and everything
was uniquely determined here.
You had to crimp this guy first.
There was no choice.
And the tricky part
of the algorithm
is when you have choice, when
you have multiple equal angles,
you don't know what
to crimp first.
The algorithm just
crimps one of them first,
but then it might
have to fix things.
So I came up with
a simple example
where you have to do that.
I think it will help clarify
how this merging really happens.
So the example is-- it's hard
to draw an equilateral triangle
with accurate angles,
but I'll do my best--
and then these are supposed
to be right angles.
OK.
So that's my crease pattern.
And some of this is forced.
This guy-- at this vertex, this
is the only locally smallest
angle.
It's only 60 degrees,
these are 90.
This is bigger than 90.
So this has to be crimped
first, and it's not equal.
That means these guys are equal.
We don't really
care about those.
And it's symmetric,
so not equal, equal.
OK.
But here we have a choice.
There's two 60 degree angles.
This does not look
very flat foldable.
I think I'd better add
some more creases there.
Got to have to even
parity at every vertex.
So now we have a choice.
Do we crimp this one first or
do we crimp the other one first?
At this point, it's symmetric,
so I'll do this one first.
This'll be my pairing.
And there are two
possibilities here.
Either I crimp this one first
or crimp this one first.
The algorithm doesn't care.
So let's suppose it does
this one, because this
is the bad one.
OK.
Now we have a cycle with
an odd number not equals.
So this is not
possible to satisfy.
The algorithm
doesn't stop there.
It says, OK, I have these paths.
There's a cycle here
that's a problem,
then I also have a path up here.
How does it go?
There's a path that goes
here, here, here, here.
And there's a path
that goes here.
But really it looks at the
vertices that had choice.
It says, look, at
this moment I had
a choice between whether to
fold this angle or this angle.
In general, it might have
been a bunch of equal angles.
We see here that there's a cycle
that the other choice would've
involved a path.
And so we merge.
In general, if there's
two different things--
one could be a cycle,
one could be a path,
they could both be cycles,
they could both be paths,
whatever-- if I ever
have the opportunity
to join those two parts
together I'll do it.
So in other words, I do
the other crease first.
Let me draw that.
What that means will become
clear once we actually do one.
So I want to do this first.
The rest is the same.
OK.
So in that situation, what do
my paths and cycle look like?
Well, there was this path
that started over here.
It used to go like this, but
now this vertex has changed.
So it's going to do something
different at that vertex.
Now it goes over this way.
I'm just following
the constraints.
Now those two guys are
constrained to be different.
And these are
constrained to be equal.
So lo and behold we merged
a path and the cycle
and we got a single path.
The other paths remain the same.
Just these two guys
got interchanged.
What we're doing is basically
turning here and turning here
instead of going that
way and going that way.
And whenever you have two pieces
like this, and one of which
is a cycle, you will do a merge.
Merging can only help
us, because they'll
get bigger and
bigger and bigger.
The bigger these
sets of constraints
are, essentially,
the better chance
that you'll get
the parity right.
I can never-- and this
is argued in the notes,
but few-- it never hurts to
merge something, is the point.
And if you're lucky-- if you,
say, merge two odd cycles--
they will become even.
If you merge with a path,
you'll become a path.
And so you're golden.
Paths are always good.
And so this thing becomes
flat foldable, or at least
locally flat foldable.
And we can mark in a
crease pattern, I guess.
You could make this-- that's
going to be hard to see,
I think-- mountain, valley,
mountain, valley, mountain--
oh, sorry-- equals, not equals,
this is not equals, not equals,
not equals, equals.
These guys are free.
So you can make one
of them mountain,
one of--- you can make them
all mountains, I guess.
Or not.
OK.
This is a locally
valid flat folding.
And it's hard to tell
whether it actually works
except by folding it.
So here I made one.
That's the top side, I think.
Ideally I got the same
crease pattern as here.
The reds are mountains.
Looks the same.
And then--
It's clear that this pattern
is flat foldable, right?
You just simple fold
here, and then you've
got a single vertex and that
single vertex is flat foldable.
But this does not do that.
It does a kind of twist.
It's kind of a fun mountain
valley assignment for it.
So in this case it works.
In general, you might get
some weird mountain valley
assignment that doesn't work.
But something simple
like this pattern,
which has four
vertices, always will.
Any more questions
about local foldability?
That gives you at least an idea
of what the merges look like.
It's hard to draw a huge
example, but-- Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So the
generic case, you
don't really have
a choice at any--
PROFESSOR: In the generic
case you have no choices,
and so you've got to-- you
just check, does it work.
And if it--
AUDIENCE: If you have
an odd number of faces,
odd number of sides, then
it's not going to work?
PROFESSOR: If you have a face
with an odd number of sides,
that might be fine.
It depends on these
assignments, whether they're
not equal or equals.
Like if this were an equal
sign, then you'd be happy.
And that would
happen, for example,
if you move these
creases to be very small.
I'd have to also make this
one proportionally big, which
is possible if I move
this vertex way over here.
I'll have a triangle.
This will have a big angle.
Then I can have a
small angle here
and these two guys
will be made not equal
and these two will
be made equal,
and then the parity's fine.
So if you have a cycle with
an odd number of not equals,
then you're screwed.
In the generic case
there's nothing you can do.
When you have equal angles,
when you had a choice,
you go back and check whether
the choices would do merges.
If you do, you do them.
Overall, this turns out
to take a linear time
if you're careful, because you
can only merge so many times.
You have at most n parts and
each merge-- with some care.
You need fancy data structures
to get this to work.
You need find stuff,
but then you'll
get linear time over all.
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: So what's the
definition of merging, again?
PROFESSOR: So the
definition of merging
is you look at every time
you had a choice in running
this algorithm-- which you have
to not just run this algorithm
but you have to maintain all
the choices that you had made.
So whenever you had two
equal angles-- in general,
the algorithm is you look at
a sequence of equal angles.
The algorithm maybe
chooses the first one,
but you could have chosen any.
You see for each of the
other possibilities,
would that end up combining
two of the components.
So the constraints sort of join
together either into cycles
or into paths, like this guy.
And we just check, if
I do this other change,
does it end up combining
two of those components?
Before I had 1, 2,
3, 4 components.
Now I only have 3 components.
So just see what happens.
If that decreases the number
of components I do it.
And you can guarantee
this never hurts you.
Keep merging components
until you can't anymore.
And then either it
works and you've
got no parity problems or no
cycles, or it doesn't work.
If it doesn't work, there is
no local foldable assignment.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: When you
say it's linear,
are you counting
vertices or edges?
PROFESSOR: Let's say number
of vertices plus edges.
That's the safe way to define
n and then linear in that.
Or if you count
the endpoints here
it doesn't matter whether you
just count vertices or edges.
The sum of the two
is always safe.
So n usually just means
the size of the input,
and those vertices and edges,
so why not just count them both.
Other questions?
Cool.
So that's local foldability.
I just have a few
more little things
and then you can
ask more questions.
Oh, sorry.
I have one more example.
I forgot.
This is an example where
everything works fine.
You don't get any cycles.
But it's kind of a fun example.
The crane.
I'd never analyzed it
before, so I spent the time
to draw one of these pictures.
So first I just put a
bunch of circles down,
and I look for things that
are forced, just because that
is more interesting.
I tried to make it
as bad as possible.
It turns out I couldn't
make it that bad.
But this guy's
forced, because it's
the only locally smallest angle.
And then it's
symmetrical around.
So this guy's forced.
Four of them should be forced.
If I advance, yeah.
This one, this one.
Those are all forced
to be not equal.
The rest are equal.
The other guys have ambiguity.
And I tried.
I thought this would be a
great place to find the cycle
and then we could resolve
the cycle, because I know
this should work in the end,
but I couldn't make a cycle.
It's not possible, because
there's sort of this cut point
here.
And you once you go to
one side of the pattern,
you can't come back
to the other side.
I could make a really
long path though.
So I chose-- there's
a lot of choices here,
but the algorithm
just chooses one.
I tried to make the
longest path I could.
It's kind of a fun puzzle.
Not that hard to solve.
It gets a little hard
to draw these pairings.
Here these two guys are
paired together as not equal.
We crimp that first.
Then let's say we
crimp these two.
Then we've got two
angles here, each
of which I think is 90 degrees
after you do the crimps.
And so these two guys
have to be equal.
That's what this notation means.
So here there were, I think
four different possibilities.
And if you trace all the
paths, you get these guys.
So there's some simple paths
out here, but then there's
this purple path in the
middle, which starts here,
goes up here, over here,
over here, along this crease,
over here, here, here, here, up
there, here, here, there, back,
forth, and then it
escapes in the corner.
So you get a mountain valley
assignment out of this.
I didn't test whether
it was possible.
Probably not.
Anyway, you get something,
and it might be possible.
Exercise for you to try at home.
All right.
That took some time to draw.
Cool.
That's local foldability.
Now with the
Kawasaki condition, I
mentioned briefly
in lecture three
that-- We were talking
about convex cones, where
the amount of material is
less than or equal to 360.
Someone pointed out and
said, oh, out of paper
you can't make
something more than 360.
And it's true if you start
from one sheet of paper.
But if you start with
multiple sheets of material
and join them together, like
sew them up, like in a T-shirt,
you can get non-convex
cones, meaning
more than 360 degrees
of material here.
This is, let's say,
270, let's call it?
So you double that,
because there's
a front side and the
back side of the T-shirt.
Easier to see in a 3D one.
You've got more than 360 degrees
of material in the armpits.
So, yes, it's true.
And what happens, as I mentioned
briefly, is there's a new case.
There's sort of
two situations when
you have a kind of a mess
of material like this,
more than 360
degrees of material.
There are two possibilities.
Either you end up folding it to
lie in less than a full circle,
in terms of the boundary,
and then it's just like here.
The alternating sum
should be equal to 0.
Or you end up folding it
so that it encompasses
an entire circle,
and then you end up
with this alternating sum of
angles being plus or minus 360.
And it's in the textbook.
It's not so easy to prove
that that's all that happens,
but you-- Basically, you
can't twist multiple times,
because then you'd end
up with a crossing.
So it's not that much
harder to analyze
these kinds of situations.
You can do it.
But this is a
great excuse for me
to show cool ways
to fold T-shirts.
How many people seen this video?
most.
It's like six years old.
Have you ever tried it?
[LAUGHTER]
I brought an extra
little T-shirt here.
This is totally for fun.
You pinch here and here.
Bring this side over here.
You pinch.
You do a nice
flourish, and then you
get your perfectly
folded-- I didn't
do it perfectly--
T-shirt in one motion.
As they say, in two seconds,
and it works for us.
So it's a great T-shirts.
And for fun, here's the--
this is like the high tech way
to do it.
There's actually a whole bunch
of T-shirt folding machines.
You push the button.
It's a bunch of simple
folds, actually.
So it's a nice little
simple folding machine.
[LAUGHTER]
It's kind of fun to watch.
Seems like a lot of set up time.
You have set up time with
the fast method also.
So It's kind of fun.
The same machine. you can also
wrap them directly into bags.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Have you
in clothing stores
they have non-mechanical
versions of those
that are just plastic boards.
PROFESSOR: And you just--
AUDIENCE: That you can flop over
so that all your T-shirts are
folded the same.
PROFESSOR: It's not automated.
Yes.
You can actually buy-- I've
only seen them in stores rarely.
They're usually
in the back room.
But you can actually buy
this folding machine.
It's like a giant piece of
plastic with exactly-- maybe
only three creases,
I think typically.
And then you just do them
in some order manually
with simple folds,
and it does make
really nicely folded T-shirts.
Nicer than I could
fold by hand, anyway.
All right.
That was just for fun.
While we're on the
topic of T-shirts.
Next question is about
higher dimensions.
So I mentioned
briefly, yeah, you
can do higher
dimensional origami.
Not much is known about it.
So a natural thing to ask
about is flat foldability
for higher dimensions.
And there are exactly
two papers about this.
Well, maybe even just one.
The old one is this paper
by Kawasaki-- same guy
as Kawasaki's condition--
and this is in this book.
This the first--
this is a hard book
to get a copy of,
First International
Meeting of Origami
Science and Technology.
These days it's called
Origami Science, Math,
and Education, OSME.
And this T-shirt is from
the latest one, which
was in Singapore two
years ago, I think, 2010.
Next one is in a
year or two in Japan.
So this is the very first one.
This is before my time.
And there's this paper.
It's a translated Japanese
paper, so it has a few typos.
We also have the
Japanese original
if you're interested in
reading this some time.
You see, for example,
here is folding
a regular piece
of paper in half.
Here's folding a 3D
solid of paper in half.
A little harder to
imagine, but there it is.
And let's see,
what's in this paper?
There's a definition,
although I would really
call it a necessary condition.
I think this is not
a good definition
of flat origami in 3D.
But there it is.
This is the definition.
What it says is basically,
locally everything works out.
When you do a fold,
it's like a reflection.
If you do it
instantaneously, this
is like reflecting this
piece through the line
for flat folding.
This is like reflecting this
piece through the plane.
And so one condition you
have is that if you-- it's
easier to look at one of
the examples in the paper.
So you have this
crease pattern, which
you can draw by a bunch
of planes, let's say.
If you kind of walk
around and say, OK, I
go through this
crease, which means
I reflect through
that plane, then
I reflect through this plane,
this plane, this plane,
you can take any sort of path,
any cycle through this world.
In the end I should end
up back where I started.
Otherwise I'm ripping.
And what that condition
says is that if you
take the sequence of reflections
and you compose them,
you end up with no reflection
at all, that nothing moved.
And so that's a necessary
condition for flat foldability.
I wouldn't call it a definition,
although this paper did.
Natural definition
is more like what
we draw in 2D for
flat folding, where
we add another layer,
another dimension,
and then guarantee no
collisions in that dimension.
So same thing in 3D.
It's just harder to imagine
stacking up copies of 3D.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Doesn't the
reflection analogy
only apply to
simple folds, where
the plane goes all the way?
PROFESSOR: OK.
Good question.
The reflection
analogy definitely
applies to simple folds.
It also applies to
non-simple folds.
But it does require
straight folds,
which here mean flat
folds, like planar folds.
For curve creases,
you're not really
reflecting, because
you can't fold
a curve crease all the way.
You can't fold it flat.
But whenever you fold
something all the way-- so even
in something like this, which is
not a simple fold in the end--
you can check.
Essentially, this is what we--
on the circle, when we said,
OK, you walk this way and then
you just change direction.
That's essentially
the reflection
that's happening on the circle.
If you live on the circle
you're reflecting in
that you're immediately
bouncing back at that crease.
It turns out to
hold in 2D as well.
So if you look at the
effect of this crease,
it is that you're reflecting
this part over that crease.
I guess you can see
it in the folding too.
I mean, you go over this
crease, then you hit this line,
and then you immediately
bounce back at the line.
That is actually a
reflection through the line.
Good question.
It's obvious for simple
folds, but reflection actually
works here as well.
We'll talk more about that in
the next lecture, I believe.
OK.
I was looking up reference,
any papers that cited that one,
and there's basically
one paper, which
is this kind of a
graphics/art/math paper talking
about four-dimensional origami.
It's basically some
simulations and some examples.
Here's the not folding
all the way picture.
A little harder to imagine.
Here they're doing, I think, the
4D analog of a rabbit ear fold.
Little hard to
tell, but first they
do a simple fold
along a bisector.
That I can understand.
And then they do an
inside reverse fold.
And then you end up with
1/4 of the tetrahedron.
So if you divide, this is the
centroid of the tetrahedron.
It's really hard to
draw these pictures.
In the paper, they
actually showed two images,
and if you align
them with your eyes
then you'll see
a 3D image, which
is of course a projection
of the 4D thing.
They also have this one.
Anyone have red-blue
glasses with them?
Then you'll see this in 3D.
Here you can watch that later.
This is their 4D analog of
a flapping bird, I guess.
It's pretty hard to see
these pictures, though
But this is the state of the art
in 4D origami as far as I know.
It's kind of neat to find.
This is a pretty recent paper.
Questions about
higher dimensions?
Lots of things are open.
For example, single
vertex flat foldability
could be a neat problem.
I don't think-- It may be
that Kawasaki's condition
from that paper is enough.
I don't know.
Maybe not.
OK.
Last question, just kind
of a nice place to end
is, why are we spending all
this time on flat foldability.
Flat origami's kind of boring.
And so why do we spend
all this time with it?
It's good to check
why are we doing this.
One answer of course is that
there's interesting mathematics
here.
It's kind of a natural question.
Why not?
That's the math cop-out answer.
But there are actually a
lot of good answers as well.
One answer is that flat origami
actually is pretty cool.
There's a whole world of
flat tessellations, where
you fold a repeating
pattern in your sheet.
This is from a
rectangle of paper.
What you're seeing here
is a shadow pattern.
It's held up to a window, and
so you see this shadow pattern,
which looks an awful lot like
a 6 by 6 by 6 Rubik's cube.
That's the design here.
You could make it even
larger if you want.
Another answer is, well,
maybe I need to store stuff.
And while I can
unfold things, it's
kind of big when it's unfolded.
If I could fold it
all the way flat--
maybe I care about the 3D
shape, but if I could fold it
all the way flat, then it
would be easier to store.
It's going to be smaller, more
compact, I can roll it up,
I can do lots of things.
Airbag folding is one example.
Here you actually
start with a 3D shape.
There's no sort of unfold.
It's been sewn into a 3D shape.
And then you want to collapse
it into some nice flat shape
for storage in your steering
wheel, or the side of your car,
or whatever.
And this is an example of
folding using flat origami
designs.
This crease pattern is
based on the tree method,
and other stuff we haven't
covered yet, fold and cut.
So that's another.
That's sort of the
practical answer.
And then there's more
mathematical answers,
deeper things.
Even if you don't care about
flat folding by itself,
it turns out to relate
to 3D folding as well.
This is a paper
that's very cool.
We have a guest lecture by
Tomohiro Tachi coming up.
I haven't scheduled
exactly when it will be,
because it's in the in the box.
It's on tape.
So we'll be watching
that at some point.
He was actually just
visiting a couple weeks ago.
And he has this
cool theorem which
says that if you
have a plane or quad
mesh-- so a particular kind of
crease pattern, every vertex
has four incident increases,
every face is a quadrilateral--
and it's flat foldable--
so you may not
care about flat
foldability, but you
need this Kawasaki
condition to guarantee
that this will work-- then it
has a rigid folding motion, if
and only if it has a 3D state.
Let me show you some examples.
So this a kind of a classic
origami called miura-ori.
And it has this cool property
that even if these panels are
made up out of rigid material
like sheet metal or plastic
or whatever, if these are
hinges you can still fold it.
And this is an
animation of it folding.
And indeed it folds flat.
And what the
theorem is saying is
if you can build a 3D picture
like this, any one of these,
that guarantees that there's
this folding motion-- not
necessarily all the way to flat,
but at least part way to flat.
And often you can get
it all the way to flat.
And so Tomohiro's
developed software
that lets you start
with something
you know works-- so this
is a miura-ori that's
been folded partly--
and then just start
pulling on the vertices and
messing it up and just changing
the shapes.
So this is not a folding.
You're changing how the
paper fits together.
You're changing
the crease pattern.
As you do that, he keeps
track of the crease pattern
and he adds constraints
to make sure
that it stays flat foldable.
The result is you end up with
a 3D embedding, a 3D folding,
and you have a flat
foldable crease
pattern that goes with it.
And that guarantees
that you get a motion.
Those two things.
So this technique of
having flat foldability
lets him design crazy
crease patterns that
fold into whatever
shape he wants
with a nice rigid motion where
all these panels stay rigid.
So that's another motivation
for flat foldability.
It's probably used
elsewhere as well,
but this is kind of the
coolest, newest example I know,
where it's just a
condition in the theorem,
and in order to check
that condition you
need to understand
flat foldability.
Other questions?
That's all I have for slides.
Cool.
That's the end of class.